[Music]
New York City is a very hot destination
but visiting New York can be extremely
expensive a hotel can be anywhere
between 100 200 300 a thousand dollars
so I'm trying to find a good fancy cheap
hotel that's why I'm gonna stay at a pet
hotel so I'm gonna stay at the dog hotel
for 24 hours and I'm gonna review the
dog hotel experience for a human being
let's check it out all right so I got a
nice little Bobby already a first
impressions smells fresh back oak
complimentary snacks right here
well a little dry
hi hello how are you where can I sue you
you'll be staying with some water I can
get you some water okay yeah thanks so
much
Oh miss your water oh thank you so much
you got it you okay so you guys have
only doggie bowls right yes only doggie
bowls and the waters Poland Spring not
tap that's delicious water I never knew
water would taste better out of a doggy
Bowl what are my options you guys have
any rooms available we have three
different suite options we have tons of
them available I can take you down now
let's go see Joe yeah let's go check by
the way do dogs have any like herpes or
anything that I can get from the doggy
ball no not at all wow these two right
here are our uber suites these are the
biggest Uther's 299 scale of one to ten
how comfortable this bed is I'm gonna
give it a 10 we got a little teddy bear
here that Oh No okay um do you see this
a little hole in its back and then you
have treadmills for like the ADHD dogs
this is our gym called pants so it's
good for the dogs who have a little more
energy we really use it in the winter
too when this salt is out there it's bad
for their paws so they like to go on it
release some energy this is a step below
this is our sensational sweets and these
are 129 a night and there's that close
to the rich dogs
yeah is there ever like a little like
they stare out from each other's glass
to be like you little rascal they
usually pass out when they come down for
dinner they eat their dinner
right to bed the paw prints for like
crazy nights you know those hotel
reviews where they like flash the light
and they see all the sperm here if you
flash a light you just see a lot of dog
prints and this is our most basic this
is our standard suite and it's just good
for dogs who are usually you know rescue
dogs who don't like cages but it's just
our basic this is 89 a night that's
cheaper than most hotels in New York
this is the life
okay this dog is like come down is it
living in the ceiling where's that name
is GoPro this one is really comfy and
it's cheaper than most hotels in New
York so I think I'm gonna go with this
room how many dogs I think peed in this
bed well actually I don't care cuz I'm
gonna be peeing in this bed tonight so
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'll be quiet
this is better than my apartment in New
York City you can't get a room this big
do you think it's gonna be weird doing a
conference call from here so now I'm
gonna check out their room service I
just asked for some food I said surprise
me bring me whatever you guys have oh my
god and it says my name on it thank you
so much
smells fresh this food is way more fun
than like a dish like I don't the steak
because you know what you can't do a
steak you can't take it like this and
can't be like II I'm not even joking
this doesn't taste bad okay I think I've
explored the room I'm gonna go I'm gonna
check out what else this hotel has to
offer
but so far did she lock me in can you
open the door yeah okay please open the
door okay all right I need to get my
energy out I've been in this room for
way too long we got some treadmills
right here I'm gonna explore all the
funky stuff this hotel has so let's
let's see oh I don't think the
treadmills are working I don't need a
treadmill what I'm gonna do
all right so now I'm gonna check out the
lounge area where all the dogs hang out
I'm gonna go meet some dogs it's right
in there
huge they got little dogs right here and
then they got some big dogs in the back
I'm a big dog I think we'll see where
they place me but let's go check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
Oh full day of activities I'm exhausted
I'm sweaty I'm stinky I'm covered in
here what does every hotel need a good
shower so I'm gonna go wash up
go to bed nice and clean I'm just
getting a shower I just need to take a
shower I get it I'm sexy I get it you've
never seen a naked man before okay so
this is the dog reading section
they cut the dog's hair right here pink
blow-dryer you can get your nails done I
think you can dye your hair too if you
want here they can like give you
different hair dyes they got all these
soaps
[Music]
all right this is a successful shower I
wasn't even expecting to have a shower
here so let's go get Johnson's go to bed
okay that was a lot of adventure I'm
exhausted back in the room closing the
door and today I'm just gonna try and go
to bed now oh okay it's kind of quiet no
the dogs are barking or anything there's
one dog just kind of moaning a little
bit I don't know if it's like having fun
with a little teddy bear somewhere or
something but I'm just gonna try and go
to sleep now huh
I have to go I have to go to the
bathroom real bad I don't know where
they told me to just go on the floor or
get a pee bad but I didn't get a peepee
bad I can't just do it on the floor oh
but I have to go poopy so bad I can't
poop on the floor and then have him
clean him up to clean it up tomorrow and
like look me in the eyes as I check out
I can't do that that's the only - about
staying here because pooping in a
bathroom is way more comfortable than
pooping on the floor and knowing that
they're gonna have to clean it up I just
gonna have to hold it in and this dog
has not stopped moaning I don't know
what it's doing it's everyone it's all
the dogs are quiet maybe if I move back
and it'll stop
I think it stopped
it's the retain am thirsty I gotta go to
my doggie ball
[Music]
guys what am I doing with my life
hmm didn't know you can you looking like
that
no go back go back to that I'm sorry I'm
going to bed
all right so it is now 8 a.m. and I did
it and honestly I only woke up a few
times my neck doesn't hurt my body
doesn't hurt I think I've gotten used to
the smell
best hotel experience I ever had right
like because fancy you know a fancy is
crappy you know what crappy is dog hotel
you don't know what that is all you know
is that movie that whatever it was on
Disney Channel that's all you know about
dog hotels and now I got to live that
Disney dream of mine I got to go poop
again so yeah I definitely have to get
up I think this dog food is acting a
little funky on my stomach alright
alright thanks for watching
my
[Music]
you
[Music]